i'm a stinky boy though yeah
did were you a little were you a little
stinky peepee boy
after the fight this weekend oh the
fight did you pee yourself from
excitement
i did i mean i did i had to hold my i
was enjoying it so much
that i had to hold i almost peed myself
because i was holding it the whole time
right
because i watched all eight rounds i
could not peel my eyes off the screen it
was so good
glued right yeah it's thir when made
their mayweather was like
i hope i hope the fans were entertained
were we ever
oh my god were we ever man
i mean it was um enthralling i would say
almost like we talk
about fighting a lot now on the podcast
and so like i've gotten into watching
ufc and stuff like that but this
bar none was the best fight i've ever
seen in my entire life yeah
and i can say that with confidence when
we were when we were watching it on the
the bootleg stream because showtime
was just like so popping right like they
didn't have room for
me so you you boo you got like a but i
you know i just i just paid because like
they deserve it yeah yeah right
right right yeah yeah i actually liked
the fact that the showtime app
died every 30 seconds it gave you a
chance to like breathe because it was
just so
exactly crazy and it also felt like
every time the stream started back up
yeah it was like the first time yeah so
it was just like renewed excitement
every single time dropped right in the
middle of round four and you're like
oh i didn't even know round three was
over it's like playing a slot machine
right
exactly it was like slime machine was
sick oh oh oh oh
oh yeah yeah every time and it felt like
i was
getting a jackpot every time yeah yeah
no i would i would agree with that
i was uh oh my god dude and so well i
have to say
i was just so drawn in that people were
trying to
talk to me while i was watching and i
had to tell them like shut the [__] up
[__] are you doing it's the greatest
fight on earth and i'm missing it
because you want to [__] talk
yeah shut up no i felt the same way
the mikos are performing
shut up have some respect and boy did
they ever perform
oh my god that was a i mean
moving again like it's just so many
emotions
yeah yeah i after i watched money bag yo
you know walk out with mayweather uh
i really thought about uh re-burying my
hamster
why i feel like i had to dig them up and
just send them out a better way i don't
know it just inspired me
gotcha gotcha just to you know reconnect
with my feelings and
right trauma i've been running away from
it right i see
i see yeah just kind of confront your
demons yeah just made me feel vulnerable
yeah yep totally which is a good thing i
mean that's what you want
you know yeah from something like that
you know
i was thinking when when logan said this
is
this is for anyone who you know this is
strictly just a message i want to send
about beating
the odds you can do it
logan did something for uh
men worldwide he brought to life the
age-old question
would you get your ass beat for a
million dollars
yeah so now that he's crossed that off
the list you know what's coming next
what the a's old
five straight frat guys in a car
hey man for a million dollars
would you like
you know s are these
yeah you know it's
you know that's next
miami july 20th 2022
which one of these tick-tockers will
suck a dick
[Music]
only on triller everyone's calling me a
[__] saying i want to suck a dick i've
sucked a lot more in my life
penis isn't [__] to me bro
dude massive drama drama yeah keep that
keep that keep that loss of drama today
bro
massive drama when brylan
and s stouden faced off today did you
see that
at the bro bro house no yeah i did they
could they confronted each other
they were like i'll suck your dick and
the other guy was like i'll suck it
better than you
for a milli for a million they put a bet
on it yeah i did
whoa yeah crazy no they got each other's
faces it was crazy like the other one
each one wanted to suck the other one
stick better
two guys screaming at each other saying
i'll make you come first
and the world just being into it like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
dude i've seen him train man i've seen
training videos
so they should just see what he's like
brothers just with porn stars
[Laughter]
yo what's up i'm in the gym with johnny
sims and his girl they're teaching me
how to [__] throat that [__] dude
don't be a throat goat this year swear
to god bro
[Laughter]
that [__] is fine man
i mean so you know hats off to logan
i'll knock you the [__] out
what you'll be knocked out after i'm
done with you
that's what i meant i would knock you
flat on your ass
put you out man you'll be so tired dude
from how hard you bust
oh man the ultimate gay chicken man
how would you do it how do you think
you'd do it
not not that
not not yeah he's like probably you know
pepper grinders that sort of thing can
we get the [__] it in here
how do you think you'd beat floyd oh
that's a great question man why don't we
candace can we
can we get a heavy bag in here
dang dang it's like kind of perfect wow
that was
that was awesome that's ideal that's
crazy so how'd you do it how would you
well all right
just a mic up over here throw the pack
on
what's up gang all right well
welcome to tony's fight camp so here's
the thing
logan's like what he's like 190. this
bag is probably like
150 right so if i
you know we're kind of more like floyd
height okay so if i'm fighting logan i
know
mayweather had a lot of you know this
okay using a lot of that right here's
what i would have did
i just came clean out
you know saying i would have had it in
the in the back
but it can't just and just switch it
oh yeah i feel like that would be
there's no
oh there's no way he's recovering from
that wait what about
what about something like this hold on i
think this is personally what i would
use right here
oh yeah yeah right here
then just [__] just a minute that was
a soft jab yeah just just testing it
just testing it oh
you want a little bit of left shank in
the stomach
you could
that's probably what i would do right
there if you're listening on audio i got
two pans right here
it's one to have the one but if i had
two frying pans in the ring
i'm feeling great just a little oh huh
i'd have been whooping logan's ass with
this
oh okay all right this is what i would
do
i put on the vr headset and just
okay oh nice what are you what are you
doing with that
it's like when you do i'm jerking them
you know what have been really crazy
what if you just pull up in the ring
like what a damn
pardon
it's good because after you kill him
with the garden right you can just pull
the dirt right over his body
and just just pat it down after you're
done [__] all right
[__] yeah and you're just you know you
and your boys and they're doing a
group break after
the ribs yeah and they're just cracking
his ass
right in the belly button
he shits himself
stop it it tickles stop
so yeah that's how that's how i would
have beat logan
what's up doug what's up doc no what do
you got
what do you got i'm saying enjoy it okay
nice
nice i was going to say just you know
what i'm saying
yeah no i'm just kidding i was just
kidding i didn't hump them i didn't hump
the bag or anything
first thing you're going to want to do
squaring up
somebody maybe you're in a bar maybe
you're in a bathroom okay first thing
you want to do
close the distance get close
unbutton his shirt
all right all right maybe you're in a
back alley
maybe it's dark you can't see it you
want to get hands on your opponent
face chest get close
get behind him tickle his belly button
[Laughter]
that's dark maybe
combat you're ducking hands you're
trying to
get out the way grab his hands
why do we fight why do we fight
turn him around smack his ass
smack his ass maybe you're in an open
area
fight hasn't started yet you say hey man
chill out plenty more where that came
from
but you're drinking tonight and you you
walk off to the bar like friends yeah
okay
okay yeah so that's how you do it yeah
okay cool
well that's how i defuse a regular you
know fight
right but if i'm fighting logan logan
logan logan floyd
oh man
this is a horrible segment on audio oh
yeah this is horrible
what's happening brutal segment on audio
so yeah if anyone's wondering about uh
you know potential
technique for logan floyd two
the sequel which would probably
definitely happen
we suggest they just bring frying pans i
think
all right cool yeah candace let's get
this so bad let's let's beam this [__]
out of here oh yeah
if you listen to that on audio i'm sorry
that was probably
really brutal you should go check it out
on video oh this is the
we can't play this i don't think oh yeah
that's a bit of a bad choice for
yeah that was the uh motion for
copyright that was a conspiracy that
uh logan was knocked out
yeah by floyd yeah bro if he was knocked
out
200 pounds falling like because when
you're knocked out that [__] is
involuntary
that's just your whole body going limp
right floyd getting hit with a sack of
200 pounds worth of potatoes just
hitting him he would have not just oh
he's just catching a football oh yeah
let me let me pick that up for you
come on baby stay upstairs that would
probably not that would knock him over
yeah
yeah yeah i really would look like a
logo putting all of his weight on it
dude there could be like a barn door
coming at you just [__]
stop yeah yeah pete i think
that's how bad
people wanted entertainment from that
that after the fact like no there's
there's
something was interesting in here
something happened
look look here's one thing that happened
someone look he almost got knocked out
for a second
yeah possibly this i think this clip
alone is probably worth 50 bucks
this is definitely 150 but it's like an
nfc worth yeah
we should ift this i'd buy the nfc for
sure it was worth 50
bucks totally people just needed a
reason to tell their friends why they
paid for it
yeah imagine inviting people over for
that and paying for it oh
yeah bad yo come over to my house dude i
don't really watch boxing no no
seriously it's going to be a good event
yeah they got to this guy they're going
to
they got the youtuber guy it's going to
be crazy did you see the ocho cinco
fight before
like the very first one yeah i watched
part of it it was pretty wild yes dece
yeah
he did solid yeah baru jack was was
pretty entertaining yeah they've used
him for a couple cards now yeah
uh yeah i don't know it was um i don't
know i
everyone i hate everyone's like dude he
caught logan paul when he knocked him
out that's how smart of a businessman he
is
stop it he made the fight go the
distance because he's he's a businessman
stop it he's a businessman he's thinking
about business all the time
how is it i just how if someone was like
hey would you
fight for a hundred million dollars he's
the only person
to generate that much money for a fight
like for an exhibition fight like this
yeah
it's not like he's making genius
business moves is it
um i mean i maybe he's genius in that
he somehow managed to just make a
[__] ton of money from fighting yeah you
know i feel
because most people in fighting don't
make a ton of money so yeah he has made
that game pay him yeah careers over you
know what i'm saying like
people couldn't hold a candle to his
earnings so in that way yeah like
and and i don't know floyd's career like
that so i don't know what
got him that amount of money but
i think maybe you could say that
but i if for i don't know how anyone
would pay for that fight when going into
the fight the dude says
if i'm a professional what do you say
legalize bank robbery
yeah i know yeah how do you not know
that he's woodwinking
at the very end or the conference after
the fight the press conference when he
wasn't even bothered yeah it's just like
a legal heist
basically yeah and everyone in the
audience is like
it's like we're the ones that got [__]
though that's why is everyone laughing
we got [__] that is impostor syndrome
to the fullest or not imposter uh like
stockholm syndrome yeah yeah exactly
yeah oh it's fine
totally floyd i love you man love me
back dude
please you're the best that yeah he just
cashed in on all his sims
yeah wait till they find out he has a
girlfriend yeah yeah exactly
wait no wait till they find out he's
i'm just trying to make picture in
people like
paying for the floyd fight and then
being like upset
that logan gets to hug floyd yeah
that's good why does logan get to that's
really good he wouldn't even like shake
my hand the meet and greet
come on i'm a tier three i paid 50 bucks
for this dude i paid 50 bucks
what the heck logan imagine the twitch
streamer fighting
thank you sex prince 21
for the bits
you